more people stay poor because of their
egos than get rich off them yeah at the
moment it seems like egos are being
valorized on the internet especially
among men's advice yeah how is it that
more people stay poor because of their
egos and get rich off them if there's a
bunch of examples of people with
seemingly big egos that also have money
I think that's um what's the fallacy
um
whatever the whatever the cognitive
follows you for what's in front of your
eyes
there you go
um I think there are far more people who
are successful and significantly more
successful than the people who are
visible on
content who and I would say many of
those people aren't actually that
successful and so if we're looking at
the objective measure of success as like
net worth just for just for the sake of
this conversation there are far more
people who are rich and Anonymous than
there are people who flaunt their
Lamborghinis that they rented for a day
now they're I mean if you really think
about the influencer world of business
there are not that many guys who
actually like are really in the game
like most of those guys sell something
from their platform about building a
platform like that's that's 90 not even
95 it's probably like 98 99 and so
there's only like a very small select
and and to be fair those guys
are all pretty humble like you look at
the Gary's you look at the the Andes you
look at the
um Tom Billy like these at my life like
you know like the guys who have become
you know in in the business space like
they're not particularly egotistical
guys and it's usually because they know
what heart feels like
and they know what it's like to be
inadequate over and over and over again
because you only can be inadequate if
you go to another level if you feel
amazing it's because you haven't moved
up
does that mean that if somebody wants to
be successful and they feel like they've
still got an ego that they need to do
some work on dissolving that I think
they just need to do harder things
like you need to fight harder opponents
like because you're waiting in this
little pool the only way you can
maintain an ego is by believing that
you're a big fish in a little Pond right
it's a big fish in whatever size Pond do
you think it is and if you're a big fish
you're not in a big enough pond it's
totally delusion
it's hard to comprehend like Bezos if
you've heard any of his interviews seems
like a very humble guy but like you
could have a hundred billionaires in a
room and he is worth the same amount as
them
and then if you had each one of those
billionaires is a thousand to
millionaires
he's still worth the same the same
amount as 1 100 whatever 100 000
millionaires ended him
so like there's just levels to it and I
think the moment you get the ego is the
moment you stop growing because you feel
like you beat the level but you just
keep repeating the love rather than
moving up because there is a harder boss
and they just haven't faced it yet
I suppose
it's an easy way you know if you were
going to a karate class uh but you
decided instead of going to the adult
one to go to the one that's Under 11's
yeah and you're gonna kick the [__] out
of all of these yeah and you video it
and you're like look at me and it just
happens to be that they're the same size
as you and like just imagine they're
like dumb on the inside but they're
human you know adult size and you're
kicking the [__] out of them it's like
yeah do it to Jones right like not gonna
happen yeah and so like
this yeah I'm just trying to say this
the way that I take this the way I mean
it I get comments from people who are
like love your humility Alex and like I
don't think I'm that humble of a guy
being real at least internally in my own
head but I am reminded daily of my
inadequacy
on the business game because like right
now we've moved up a level in terms of
like now we're now we're doing deals now
we're investing in companies we're
taking on big risks we're writing checks
like the another level of the game than
just only one not to say that owning one
business and growing it is not hard it
absolutely is a different kind of heart
but like I'm getting into this game and
I'm absolutely the small fish like
Warren Buffett made 90 billion dollars
on the trading made in apple in 2020.
one move right and so I'm like I am
entering into a game like how could I
say that I'm good like even if I was
exceptional it's still going to take 20
years to prove it
so like I can't say anything and by that
point I'll probably have other guys who
are you know who are [__] Titans at
that point to remind me of the fact that
I'm not as good as them so
in your estimation is the presence of an
ego something which artificially limits
the size of the vision of how high you
want to climb yeah 100 and because it's
you cannot you can't both say that you
are
you cannot admit death sits and say
you're awesome at the same time in my
opinion like I can't say like I suck at
all these things and then also be like
I'm the best you can't do it you either
like you suck at all these things and I
think it's the Dunning Kruger effect
which is like the more you the more you
learn about something the more the more
you realize you don't know and so I
think that if you have a tiny tiny
subset of things that you are studying
and a tiny subset of people you're
comparing yourself to then it it's
really easy to feel awesome about
yourself but if you compare yourself to
I mean I compare myself every day to
Warren Buffett and like he's my app him
and Monger like my heroes mostly because
the way they lived life and what they
like just everything about the way they
lived is something that I just love and
like I have Buffett's net worth by age
tracked and I have like mine tracked and
I'm like all right just gotta stay above
that line
at the moment I am right now but like I
had a you know like
his world was different yeah like I got
Warren didn't have Warren to learn from
yes very interesting it's um I mean you
took we spoke about this at the very
very start where you were saying you
have the opportunity of using the
blueprint that has been laid down by me
yeah so if you've got nothing to lose do
um do the me thing yeah you know you
have all of the mistakes all of the
failures and all of the successes and he
there was another one where you said the
rarer you are the rarer the people are
who share your perspective in this way
the greater your success the fewer
people you can share it with I was
playing with this quote from a land
about on from the school of life for
ages which was uh
loneliness is a kind of tax you have to
pay to atone for a certain complexity of
mind and I'm really not sure because
since I've been in Austin the complexity
of Mind thing which is that hasn't
stopped but the loneliness changed and I
figured that that was a big function of
change of environment and maybe like
whatever embracing or an acceptance of
of what was going on
but again is this a byproduct of success
that
a lot of people don't necessarily
realize it's a price that's going to be
need to be paid if you want to achieve a
ton of success you end up at this
rarified strata out in the troposphere
somewhere and you're like well you're
like five people that I can talk to that
understand what I'm going through at the
moment or another question as well
is that a combination of hubris and
self-delusion like is that true or other
things that the bus driver or the lady
that serves you at Whole Foods can
actually like relate to you on
so two questions one is I would probably
reject the notion that it's a prize
overall because like
being in like if you think about it as a
mountain there's less there's less
square footage at the top of the
mountain just is there's fewer people
there and the air is thinner it's harder
to get there harder to breathe right you
have to adjust it you have to acclimate
and the people that are around you like
there are fewer of them but you can make
the argument that they have even more
context than anyone else possibly could
so maybe the relationship you have are
potentially deeper even if they're not
humans don't need that many
relationships so like you just have a
smaller pool to choose from but like
most people only have two or three good
relationships in their life anyways and
so like you just have a narrower pool
that you can make that selection from
and um I mean if the people that I have
interacted with who are far above that
above me on the mountain
um that's been there that's what they've
relayed to me
um
but it's only bad if you think it's a
cost
if you're okay with it because there are
plenty of people who are lonely right
now and don't have [__]
so and there's you know and you already
know this but like there's something
being lonely and Solitude you know
um
and one is seen as bad the other scene
is fine or good so in some circles that
scene is self-care so
uh so to me it just means that like I
think your tolerance or your standard
for friends raises and
I'll share this and hopefully it comes
off the right way
I entered communities as I was coming up
and was like wow everyone here is bigger
than me and then I was able to through
achievement rise through that and then I
lost context with that group and so I
think there's just more free agency a
friendship that happens on your climb up
because you're just moving between
strata more frequently than it is that
if I settled at one of these levels then
I would eventually find all the people
at that rung but if you're constantly on
the move up the mountain then more of
that is in transitionary Period on the
on the climb and it's only a problem if
you'd hate it
I don't
what don't you hate you don't hate the
fact that sort of people come and go
that some of these relationships are
kind of transient yeah it just doesn't
bother me
because I think it's like a should
statement which is like one of my big
things it's like why should I why does
it have to be why must it doesn't must
anything it just is that way and that's
fine
we'll get back to talking to Alex in one
second but first I need to tell you
about HubSpot 28 of some people's weeks
are spent reading deleting and sorting
emails which means that very much email
is not dead starting an email newsletter
means that you've got direct connection
with your audience it means that you
actually own your audience it is the
only way that you can own them without
going through a third party like a
social media platform and from HubSpot
right now you can download their free
email template that will teach you how
to make your own newsletter you can
learn how to build an amazing email
newsletter from scratch that will check
out a compiled lookbook of awesome
examples from real Publications can
learn what it takes to create a
successful email newsletter with
exceptional design unique and compelling
copy clickable calls to action and
excellent user experience and there is a
step-by-step guide about how to get your
newsletter launched so if you've been
thinking I want to start doing a
newsletter this sounds cool this sounds
like a good way for me to start writing
to build an audience that I can then
sell to or I can then move to other
platforms as well this is a fantastic
place to begin all that you need to do
to download download this free guide
that will take you from no email
newsletter to a fantastically designed
email newsletter using industry inside
information all that you need to do is
head to
clickhubspot.com Modern wisdom that's
click hubspot.com modern wisdom to
download your free email template today
what's happening people if you enjoyed
that then press here for the full
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
foreign
[Music]